okay so getting into Jeff John's green
Lancer I guess continuing on with Jeff
John's Green Lantern we get into the
origin of the Star Sapphire so this is
cool because what Jeff Jones was going
to do is actually retcon a lot of the
existing information with regards to
star sapphires but it's also really the
first time he's expanded on the
emotional spectrum and what I mean by
that is when he was doing his his Green
Lantern run he was doing a lot of things
at the same time in the immediate it was
focusing on stories here and there that
were kind of revamping characters so
going back and redoing the origin of Hal
Jordan introducing the star sapphires
and their new origin that kind of a
thing and the backdrop of it all this
Sinestro Corps was growing the celestial
crow was expanding nobody really knew
about it I mean it was kind of there but
it was something that people weren't
wholly aware of what this does is it
said okay look you know here the new
version of the star sapphires and it
just kind of introduces this so Geoff
Johns can come back and reference it
later on now that's why I say this was
kind of a big deal because the star
sapphires have a pretty huge origin I
mean kind of going all the way back to
the Golden Age the star sapphires were
there but it wasn't really until DC
showcase number 22 in 1959 that the star
sapphires played more of a significant
role now keep in mind one of the whole
ideals with the star sapphires back in
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that here in a second but one of the
whole ideas of the star sapphires back
then was just kind of bolstering the
Green Lantern landscape but what this
does is it basically picks up with the
idea of Carroll fairs becoming a star
sapphire yet again and again this is
immediate this is fast the star sapphire
just shows up says you've been a star
sapphire before you have a one person
above all others that Hal Jordan
cherishes you are going to become a star
sapphire and you are going to serve the
purpose of being one of us and helping
us to basically defeat Hal Jordan and
get our revenge and then kind of take
over the world and that sort of thing
now of course at this point we switch
over to cowgirl and that's one of the
reasons why I wanted to cover the
character of Jillian Pearlman in our
previous discussions we were talking
about how Jordan wanted that whole
relationship between the two of them and
you know how Jordan shortcomings and so
on and so forth because Jillian Pearlman
becomes the next star sapphire in the
sense that Carol Ferris kind of shows up
and begins freaking out and of course
immediately goes after Hal Jordan
immediately recognizing the star
sapphire on site that leads to a bit of
a conflict between the two but the heart
of Hal Jordan is with Jillian Pearlman
remember Carol Ferris had made it quite
clear that there was not going to be a
relationship between her and Hal Jordan
there was in the past there was only one
of those things works like what's in the
past is in the
let's leave that then we are coworkers
and that's really the extent of it
that's the limit of it now for the star
sapphire really kind of hits home at the
idea then how George instill cares about
Kayle affairs and how could he not I
mean they suddenly just have too much
history together they've been together
for too long they were really kind of
associated with each other too much they
had a very physical and a very
passionate relationship together so it
only makes sense that those feelings
would be maintained but recognizing that
Hal Jordans heart at least at the moment
is with Jillian Pearlman with cowgirl
this star sapphire abandons Carol Ferris
and merges with Jillian merged with
cowgirl which in turn makes her the
newest version of the star sapphire now
this is when we get into Jeff John's
kind of going back and changing things
and that's why I wanted to wait until
this moment to sort of bring this up
again this is a quick three issue story
it's not long by any standard of
measurement but with the original Star
Sapphire not really the original but
with the Carol Ferris Star Sapphire the
idea was it at the time Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern was still pretty much new
and so because of that the idea was to
basically expand him grow him you know
get people introduced to the new
landscape of the Green Lantern and what
it meant but the other half was to
basically introduce kind of an
antithesis to the Green Lantern itself
now Sinestro would already been
established semester was the bad guy he
had a yellow ring Green Lantern's were
just weak to the color yellow for
whatever reason I mean we know now that
is parallax but at the time there really
was no definitive reason given back then
it was just their weaknesses the color
yellow and that's just the way it is and
he just kind of had to accept it and you
know go with the stories accordingly but
that was the bad guy the idea was to
introduce somebody who could potentially
be a love interest or at the very least
somebody who could kind of prey on the
feelings of Hal Jordan and that came in
the form of his love interest Carol
Ferris now the way to star sapphires
functioned back then in the 1950s and
1960s was that they were basically just
a race of women who wanted to prove they
were better than guys and that was it
like there was no grandiose you know
huge grand pooh-bah I think some massive
background story that was all there was
to it they basically were able to mimic
the power of the Green Lantern and Star
Sapphire became an enemy of Hal Jordan
now this eventually led into characters
like Deborah Camille Darnell I think it
was who was a star sapphire at one point
in time it was always this reoccurring
theme that kept coming back and it was
an attempt by DC to always sort of
reinvigorate and revamp interest in the
Green Lantern landscape the problem is
that it never really worked out because
at the end of the day there was really
no um
there was no gumption behind the
character it was just an arbitrary
villain out there somewhere did no one
really understood or knew anything about
and so with Geoff Johns where he comes
back and he says okay
that whole origin of the star sapphire
is just wanting to be better than guys
that's not the way it works anymore
the way it worked is that in the
beginning when the guardians of the
universe basically began the process of
shedding their emotion that they went to
all the members all these different
races and said look you guys need to
shed your emotion you know these members
of the guardians you have to walk away
from your emotion you have to abandon
you know the emotional spectrum so that
you can have logic and reason that guide
your lives there were some that broke
away and some that said no we are not
going to follow this path and they began
to experiment with different types of
emotions now a handful of these where
you know a group of women who basically
began to really kind of travel around
the universe for billions of years
trying to find different aspects of the
emotional spectrum to tap into remember
the emotional spectrum is not something
you can just go and grab right like you
can't go to the corner store and say I'd
like the emotion of compassion if you
don't mind it doesn't work that way you
know it's really one of those things
readers kind of have to unlock it
harness it tap into that power so to
speak and with these particulars a
miron's what they had done is they had
come across a planet whereby it was
really like the last remaining men and
women so to speak or the last male and
female and what they discovered is that
in their final moments a sort of Adam
and Eve Romeo and Juliet sort of
scenario you know assuming that they
were the last living members of their
race the lover of the two of them had
taken form in a physical object there
was basically more like a rock or a
stone or a gym of some kind and the
result is that it bonded itself with one
of the zamarons now this eventually led
to the formation of the xamarin culture
I guess you know the star sapphire group
which in turn began the process of going
around and trying to find people you
know that could be used as their avatars
to basically expand their numbers which
led to them encountering Carol Farris
now that part in terms of their numbers
growing and trying to expand and so on
that's Geoff Johns grabbing the original
Star Sapphire mythos but that's really
the only original aspect of it that he
grabs everything else is totally
different because of the fact that the
star sapphires believe that love is the
greatest of all the emotions what they
do is they basically a bond or at least
as far sapphire Bond's itself to a host
which in turn mates with somebody in
particular and then in cases all life in
this kind of gem construct basically
keeping it in a state of suspended
animation and so if we were to like
this too like a crazy person it would
basically be like if somebody believed
that you were perfect the way you are
they loved you that much they wanted to
keep you perfect they would in case you
in suspended animation and you would be
stuck that way forever almost turning
you into kind of like a trophy or a doll
of some kind and so because of that
following the star sapphires isn't
necessarily death per se it's kind of
like living death in the sense that they
basically encased entire planets and
living crystal and that's the fate that
befall Hal Jordan should he made where
the particular star sapphire and that's
what makes them so dangerous now again
the star sapphires are governed by love
and compassion is the overriding factor
of who they are much in the same way to
the Red Lanterns are governed by rage
and anger this star sapphires are the
same way but should how Jordan mate with
Carol fares at the star sapphire or
Jillian Pearlman as a star sapphire it
would basically result in the complete
conquering of the planet Earth the whole
earth being encased in crystal and
that's really about it and so it's
always this cat-and-mouse game when the
star sapphire will show up it'll chase
down Hal Jordan he'll just kind of have
to evade and that'll be it now one of
the other things that Geoff Johns kind
of does here is he adds a little bit of
comedy in this you know what Hal girl
kind of shows up tries to harness Hal
Jordan is this idea that like her
attraction to him physical and otherwise
immediately seizes control and it's
almost kind of comedic you know it's
almost kind of funny in the sense that
is just like all I'm running away from
the chick who's crazy and just won't let
me go but because of the power of the
star sapphire because of the fact that
it's really one of these things worse
like the ex-girlfriend versus the
current girlfriend it really just kind
of turns into a battle between Star
Sapphire and Carol Fairs Carol Ferris
becomes a Green Lantern at the end of
the day however where Jillian Pearlman
is basically defeated ultimately this
leads into the arrival of the zamarons
and a battle between them and Hal Jordan
now again it's really this notion that
they intend to kind of take him down and
put him in a situation where they're
like look choose which one you're going
to mate with you're going to mate with
one choose one of them or we're going to
kill you you know we're going to kill
either one of them so you have to choose
now ultimately he chooses neither he
says no he hasn't chosen either one of
them and so because of this he actually
kind of runs up on one of those a
alien chicks and like kisses her and so
the star sapphire is like she's chosen
her you know and so the star sapphire
just kind of races off and bonds with
this this alien chick which results in
them having to forcefully remove it
meaning they have to basically retreat
and go back to their base of operations
but again this is not
- like established Carol Ferris as the
new Star Sapphire going forward it's
basically designed to say here are what
the star sapphires are here are what the
star sapphire is about basically saying
we're going to see them return we're
going to see them play a role in the
realm of Geoff Johns Green Lantern again
this is basically what he did with a lot
of these things for example as part of
this story in the backup features there
was tales of the Sinestro Corps
basically us learning about the
different members of the Sinestro Corps
that have existed over the years and the
purpose that they serve why they were
chosen so on and so forth it's kind of a
cool little series of stories we might
cover those once we get closer to
Sinestro Corps war but ultimately when
they remove this Star Sapphire gem from
the head of this exam we're on who's
been chosen again this is Geoff Johns
building up what we're going to see with
the Green Lantern's it's really the
first introduction that we get with
regards to everything else that's going
on we have of course what looks like the
orange lantern stone we end up having me
of course the Green Lantern's and then
we have the star sapphires but there's
also for other aspects of the emotional
spectrum and so it was again geoff johns
basically saying hey look guys here's
the first time we're really delving into
the origin of another aspect of the
emotional spectrum but there's so much
more to come later on down the line plus
there's also talk of a war of course we
know that kind of being Cliff Sinestro
Corps war slash you know blackest night
so again it's basically building up and
saying the Green Lantern mythos as you
know it is about to expand by a huge
margin there's going to be so much more
that's introduced then you can imagine
at this point in time so again it was
really kind of setting the stage sort of
wetting our palate giving us an idea of
what things were coming later on down
the line which of course as we know ends
up turning out to be pretty awesome so
in any event again this was a pretty
short story I mean it was only three
issues long not a whole lot of
explanation there really just kind of a
chance to sort of give us a new origin
for a group that had previously existed
kind of bolster their ranks show us that
there's more to the emotional spectrum
but uh but yeah guys anyway if you are
new here to come as explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob Court you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]